10 ans après toujours sur le même banc
aucune évolution et vous êtes vraiment
des dégâts
vous avez tout raté le brevet vous
n'avez pas eu le permis de conduire vous
l'avez pas eu même le covid vous l'avez
pas eu
l'autre vie elle a changé déjà qui est
un projet pro qui vient de se valider
maintenant il faudra pas sucer après
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'ils sont trop bizarres les
deux hein
je peux plus me le voir qu'est-ce que tu
fais là ceinture mes culottes
on va dire que j'ai voulu aller j'ai
voulu sniffer les culottes de Maëva
gaina avec ton histoire de téléréalité
là ton image là c'est foutu aucune
stricte crédibilité finie
avec une quarantaine de concerts
nécrophile c'est imposé comme la star du
moment
ils pensent que ça fait pas le bonheur
mais qui sont cons
à l'instant le dernier son de nécrophile
sur skyrock dans Planète
on dit qu'il y a une similitude dans ton
écriture avec fianso je suis un session
avec fiansola on bosse une volonté
ça va pas trop loin non plus
je maîtrise la situation
c'est
pas possible
c'est vrai que j'ai parlé un peu trop
fort là